live local now good evening the search
is on tonight for a suspect police say
shot a man during a robbery attempt in
chinatown and that victim in critical
condition tonight thanks for joining us
here at six i'm denise valdez and i'm
christian casadas it happened early this
morning around three o'clock madison
kimbrough is at the restaurant on spring
mountain road with the latest madison
described as a senseless and vicious act
the man a waiter here at shanghai taste
right here in chinatown is trying to was
trying to stop the attacker when he was
shot multiple times and now he's
fighting for his life he was immediately
taken to umc where he is now in critical
but stable condition as for the suspect
we know it's a black man he was last
seen wearing a blue hooded sweatshirt
and white shorts now it's unclear if the
suspect got away with anything or if
there's security footage of him running
off here's what someone who works at
another restaurant nearby had to say
about this scary incident
you know as somebody that does work in
this vicinity in fact right
only a few doors down it's
pretty scary knowing that somebody would
even go to the lengths to do that and
for what something so petty it worries
me for my fellow co-workers and the
people in this plaza
shanghai taste will be closed today and
tomorrow and in a facebook post they
mentioned that for the remaining of the
year they will donate their proceeds to
wang the waiter and his family in
support now we did hear from the owner
of shanghai taste and we're going to get
information from him coming up at 11 p.m
so we'll have an update then reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now